INTRO:
Android is one of the most popular operating
systems in the entire world with an active
user base of 2.5 billion people.
Many people swear by Android and would never
even consider iOS thanks to Android’s versatility
and freedom.
Considering this popularity and strong fanbase,
you would think that Android’s founder is
a business icon like Bill Gates or Steve Jobs,
but this is not exactly the case.
In fact, there’s a large group of people
who despise the founder of Android, Andy Rubin.
Google actually paid Andy $90 million to leave
the company in October of 2014.
And when the details regarding his resignation
from the company became public, 20,000 Google
employees participated in a walkout protest.
Things actually got so heated that many shareholders
filed lawsuits against Google, and Google
would end up settling for $310 million in
2020.
From Google’s perspective, there’s no
doubt that this $400 million along with the
estimated $50 million they paid to acquire
Android were more than worth it.
But the same cannot be said about Andy given
that he not only missed out on billions of
dollars by selling to Google but also lost
his reputation.
So, here’s what happened to Android’s
founder.
PRE ANDROID:
Taking a look back, Andy Rubin was born in
1963 in Chappaqua, New York.
By trade, his father was a psychologist, but
by the time Andy grew up, his father would
embark on his own entrepreneurial journey.
He opened up a marketing firm that took pictures
of the latest electronic gadgets.
This gave Andy unprecedented access to newly
released or even pre-released tech, and this
is what really sparked his interest in technology.
Andy would end up attending the local high
school in his city called Horace Greeley High
School and he would graduate in 1981.
Following his primary education, Andy would
enroll in Utica College and major in computer
science.
Despite this background in software, Andy
didn’t instantly pick up a coding job at
a tech firm.
His first job out of college was at Carl Zeiss
X-ray Microscopy where he primarily worked
with robotics.
It seems that early on in his career, Andy
didn’t have larger-than-life ambitions.
He simply wanted to work on robotics and see
the world.
This desire led him to Geneva Switzerland
where he got a job at a Swiss firm as a software
engineer.
This job didn’t last long though as Andy
would soon take a vacation that would change
the trajectory of his life.
After a year in Geneva, Andy decided to take
a trip to the Cayman Islands in 1989 where
he would run into an Apple engineer named
Bill Caswell.
Bill and Andy quickly became friends thanks
to their shared interest in engineering, and
Bill would end up offering Andy a job at Apple.
Andy of course took the job and would end
up as a manufacturing engineer at Apple.
This is actually where Andy would earn the
nickname of “Android” from his coworkers
due to his obsession with robotics, but it
wasn’t all sunshine and rainbows.
Apple as a whole wasn’t doing all that well
during this time period.
Steve Jobs had been fired years before this
and Apple was slowly bleeding out.
So, in 1992, Andy switched over to a spinoff
of Apple called General Magic that seemed
to have better potential.
Most of us have probably never heard of General
Magic given that the company shut down 20
years ago.
But, within the tech world, General Magic
is often credited as being the most important
dead company in Silicon Valley.
They worked on several groundbreaking technologies
including smartphones, mobile operating systems,
e-commerce, social media, and even emojis.
There’s even a full-on documentary on General
Magic if you’re interested.
But, while they had game-changing ideas, these
visions never turned into tangible success.
And Andy would switch to WebTV in 1995 and
become a communications engineer.
WebTV focused on making the internet accessible
through TVs and would be acquired by Microsoft
for $425 million in 1997 and turn into MSN
TV.
Andy stuck around for a few years after the
acquisition, but in 1999, he would decide
that he was done with jumping from one tech
company to another.
He wanted to work on something much larger,
so in 1999 he would quit his job at Microsoft
and found his first company.
FOUNDING ANDROID:
Andy’s first company wasn’t Android but
actually a company called Danger Inc.
Andy co-founded this company with two of his
friends including Joe Britt and Matt Hershenson.
The company focused on creating software and
services for mobile devices, and one of their
first major partnerships was with T-mobile.
If you were born in the early 1990s, I’m
sure you remember the Tmobile sidekick.
It was that phone that you could slide open
and type on using a full keyboard.
Danger was actually the company that wrote
all the software for this device, and they
also played a significant role in the design
of the phone as well.
The default search engine used on these devices
was Google.com and this would catch the attention
of Larry Page.
Larry and Andy would end up meeting in 2002
at a Stanford event, and this would be the
beginning of a decade-long relationship.
Danger would go on to release several iterations
of the sidekick, but Andy wanted to focus
on the software side of Danger.
So, in 2003, he started a side project called
Android with a few others.
The original goal of the project was to create
an open-source operating system for digital
cameras, but they quickly switched over to
cell phones.
Android was initially just a side project
that Andy worked on during the winter, but
in 2004, he would leave Danger and go all-in
on Android.
By this point, Larry had known Andy for a
few years and could easily see the potential
of Android.
So, very early on in the project, Larry offered
to acquire Android.
It was never revealed how much exactly Google
paid for Android, but given the total amount
Google spent on acquisitions in 2005, it’s
estimated that they only paid $50 million.
This is quite ironic given that Microsoft
would end up acquiring Danger for ten times
that amount just a few years later.
It’s not clear if Andy held onto his stake
in Danger or not, but sticking at Danger would’ve
been the better financial move in the short
term.
In the long term though, there’s no doubt
that switching to Android was the right move.
Once Android was acquired by Google, Andy
no longer had to worry about funding issues
or stability as Google could easily support
the operation.
So, he focused on trying to create an operating
system for a phone with a physical keyboard.
But, once the iPhone launched in 2007, it
was clear that Android had to target the smartphone
market.
The problem though was that they weren’t
the only large players with such ambitions.
HTC, Motorola, Samsung, Sprint, T-Mobile,
Qualcomm, and TI all wanted to create their
own open-source operating system for smartphones.
But, Android had a multi-year development
lead on all the competition.
And with the Samsung Galaxy and the Google
Nexus embracing Android in 2010, there was
little doubt that Google had probably won
the mobile OS race, and Andy Rubin quickly
became one of the most important executives
at Google.
DEPARTING ANDROID:
Things were looking phenomenal for Andy.
He had more than proved his worth and Android
has since become known as Google’s best
acquisition of all time.
Personally, I’d have to disagree with this
statement as I think YouTube is Google’s
best acquisition, but there’s no doubt that
Android is definitely within the top 3.
But, despite all this positive momentum, in
October of 2014, Google would drop a bombshell.
They announced that Andy Rubin would be leaving
Google altogether to start up his own hardware
company.
This was completely unexpected not only to
the tech world but even to most of Andy’s
coworkers within Google.
None of them had expected Andy to leave Google
so abruptly given that he seemed pretty content
with his role there.
Speculation surrounding Andy’s departure
became rampant.
Did Andy get bored with Android?
Did Andy and Larry have a conflict?
Does Andy not like the direction in which
Google was taking Android and so on and so
forth.
Despite all these questions, both Andy and
Google remained pretty quiet about the situation
and after a few months, the media moved onto
the next piece of drama within the tech world.
It wasn’t till four years later that the
New York Times uncovered what truly unfolded.
According to the New York times, Google had
received a complaint from at least 1 Google
employee that Andy was involved in misconduct
and harassment.
Google apparently investigated the allegations
and determined that they were in fact credible.
It was clear to Google’s executives that
they could no longer associate themselves
with Andy.
But, at the same time, Andy had played such
an influential role at the company that they
didn’t want to just fire him.
So, they basically told Andy, Hey Andy, we
know what you did.
We’re not gonna escalate this to the authorities
or oust you publicly.
But, we also can’t have you stay here.
So, just take this $90 million and leave.
Andy of course denies all of this and claims
that his departure from Google was 100% amicable.
And technically, these allegations were never
confirmed in court, so there is no verdict
on Andy’s guilt.
Nonetheless, when the news broke, people around
the world and especially Google employees
were livid.
Many felt that Google should have fired Andy
on the spot and reported him to the authorities
instead of sending him off with $90 million.
And tens of thousands of these guys would
stage a walkout protest against Google in
late 2018.
As we touched on at the beginning of the video,
these protests would escalate into lawsuits
against Google that would stretch out for
years.
Google would apologize for the mishandling
of past cases and confirmed that no future
employee that was let go for misconduct allegations
would be eligible for a severance package.
They also agreed to invest $310 million into
new diversity, equality, and inclusion measures
that would prevent such situations from reoccurring.
And with that, Google had completely washed
their hands of Andy Rubin, but for Andy, it
wasn’t nearly that easy.
ANDY RUBIN TODAY:
After leaving Google, Andy co-founded a venture
capital firm called Playground Global.
Thanks to all of the team’s connections
within the tech world, in 2015, they were
able to raise $300 million in venture capital
from investors including Google, HP, Foxconn,
and Tencent.
They turned around and invested this money
into a bunch of tech startups with the most
popular one being Owl Labs.
Andy focused on Playground Global for a few
years, but soon enough, he returned to his
roots and founded a smartphone start-up called
Essential Products.
The company never blew up like Android or
Danger, but it did enjoy a decent level of
success.
However, this would basically evaporate overnight
once the allegations about Andy came out.
The company would hang on for a few years,
but they eventually shut down in early 2020.
Andy also left Playground Global around the
same time in late 2019.
You would think that with all these allegations
and negative press, Andy would play it safe
and stay out of the limelight.
But, in 2019, he would make headline news
again.
This time, he didn’t necessarily do anything
illegal, but he did do something that was
arguably immoral.
Apparently, Andy made his wife sign a prenup
two weeks before she gave birth to their child.
She has since filed a lawsuit against Andy
accusing him of coercing and fraudulently
inducing her to sign the prenup, but this
case hasn’t really gone anywhere.
Since then, Andy has basically disassociated
himself from all the ventures he was involved
in and has gone dead silent.
I guess it doesn’t really matter for him
given that he’s worth $350 million, but
his current situation is truly quite a shame.
Andy Rubin has ended up as the man who has
everything...
and nothing.
Do you guys prefer iOS or Android?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you respect Android even
if you prefer iOS.
And of course, consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.